foreign
good evening everyone
and welcome to this meeting of the
executive I will go through the
emergency evacuation announcement which
most of you should now be able to
rehearse word perfect but there are no
plan to fire drills so if the alarm
activates please leave the building in
an orderly fashion via your nearest fire
exit the two fire exits through the
partition doors are currently not in use
due to ongoing Works therefore the fire
exits are through the main doors of the
hall or the store room adjacent to the
stage the fire assembly point is the
island in front of the main entrance the
building please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
Council staff please note that the
meeting will be audio recorded please
switch off mobiles or turn them to
silent toilets and hand washing
facilities are available in the foyer
area
members of the public while you are of
course entitled to film or take
photographs during this meeting can I
please emphasize to you that this should
be done without disruption to the
meeting and can only be done from a
designated area
in the public seating
can I please therefore ask you to raise
your hand clearly in the air if you wish
to take photographs or film you look as
if you're already in action
members there's a need to use
microphones during the meeting when I
invite you to speak please wait until
there is a microphone in front of you
before speaking of microphones are
needed for the hearing Loop and for the
audio recording these all switched on
and ready for you to speak and will be
unmuted by officers for you please make
sure that the microphone is directly in
front of your mouth before speaking
members voting will be done on a show of
hands in line with the Constitution I
will ask for a show of hands for and
then against recommendations and will
also ask for a show of hands for those
wishing to abstain from voting
um
foreign
good evening members welcome to this
executive meeting uh on Tuesday the 7th
of March 2023
welcome to officers members members of
the public and visiting councilors and
um
if I turn to First agenda item one
apologies for absence there are none
because everyone is present
if I look to non-members attending if I
can go down the list as I see them
councilor Stuart Wilson
councilor Vilma Wilson councilor Jim
Cripps counselor Richard Lamborn
councilor Andy cross councilor Michael
Hoy I think I've captured everyone there
haven't I
sorry
yeah
hiding over on my blind spot counselor
Laureen Shaw
welcome
right if I turn to minutes uh item three
of the meeting held on the 7th of
February
um
other minutes agreed members
agreed in that case I will sign them
turning to item four to receive
Declarations of Interest
are there any Declarations of interest
on items on the agenda
no okay
questions on notice from councilors
agenda item five there are none
it shakes us onto item six
matters referred to the executive and
reports from other committees
member zero two reports from the
overview and scrutiny committee
the
excuse me the middle arts and events
center outcome of the community
expressions of Interest process and
future operating costs
uh and uh if I can turn please to you
councilor Wilson to give a report back
from uh your uh overview and scrutiny
meeting which I think was a deferred
meeting wasn't it the 23rd of February
that was deferred from uh either late
January early early February
um but if I can ask you to introduce the
report this is actually an executive
report but it was referred to the
overview and scrutiny committee so
welcome and if I could hand over to you
please okay thank you chair at the um at
the meeting on the 23rd of February we
had
presentations from groups who'd been
part of the expression of Interest
process and we took evidence from them I
think the
the feel the general feeling from the
people from the expression of interest
is from them they thought they had not
gone as well as expected from their
perspective
so that is where the recommendations
really come in to try and improve
hopefully the process going forward
would you want me to go through each
recommendation all yes I think that
would be helpful uh Council Wilson yeah
um what I will be doing as we go through
is cross-referencing to
um the item two in the report because
specifically the the uh 2.1 of the main
report on pages
6.12 and 6.13 through to 2.8 where if
you like summaries of the detail shown
in the various tables and the various
bits in the in the rest of the report so
I think it's important to understand how
the scrutiny process worked in relation
to those points
um and what I should be looking for is
for you to cross-reference the
recommendations that you've made to the
specific parts of the report and in
particular those
key outcomes so but take us through it
okay so um
the first recommendation
um came up that was The Future model for
the events center is clear and before
brought forward to full Council for
discussion the idea behind this was that
the
um
in interviewing the uh the visitors and
the people doing the expression of
Interest
what they felt was that from the overall
perspective of the council it wasn't
clear about what we were trying to
achieve so there were various options
that were available how we were going to
operate and some of those were
to say in conflicts is not quite true
but but there was um perhaps a lack of
clarity and perhaps a little bit of
um unclear what we expected from the
people doing the expressions of interest
and I think what members of the
committee wanted recommendation one is
that they wanted greater visibility and
greater input from all members of the
Council on on the expression of Interest
process and the future use of the mill
okay and where does that cross-reference
to any of the recommendations in the
main body of the report
well that specifically comes from the
evidence that was gathered from the uh
so it's stand alone
you understand yeah so that we've got
some structure so Standalone based on
the evidence from the respondents from
the ioi right so it doesn't relate to
any particular password so in terms of
scrutiny of the report yeah it's
Standalone there's no relevance to the
report is it you know yeah feedback but
and to say that it was evidence it was
gathered on the night so we wouldn't
have known about it beforehand right
okay
um because to be fair I thought that the
purpose of the scrutiny process was to
actually look at the report uh and
report back within issues within the
report so
um I'll turn to council award because I
think you know we've come back with a
response
thank you
um
yeah thank you for actually giving a bit
of clarity on that
um I I think it's important to recognize
that the executive has already set out
in the report and that's on 2.8
their intention to refer any future
proposals for operating The Mill Hall to
the overview scrutiny four scrutiny
ahead of any final decisions being taken
so it's looking at that the Future model
however the executive is willing to
accept this recommendation and refer the
future proposals directly to full
Council as was asked in this for debate
at such a point that those proposals
have been fully developed
prior to any final decision being taken
by the executive
the operation of the Mill Hall is an
executive function
and therefore the decision-making
responsibility
sits with the executive unless any
decision is outside of the agreed budget
within this report
just as a note in which case Council
would have to agree the finance but
basically we are just looking at this
report the budget and the contents in it
so as far as I'm concerned I need to
obviously to get views from my executive
colleagues but um I think as far as that
is concerned we can we can accept that
recommendation and when we come to our
own recommendations in 2.1 to 2.8 I
would like just a slight Amendment as
far as that is concerned so that it will
reread that a report will be taken back
to
full Council
to review the current performance of the
mill arts and event center and to
scrutinize the proposals for the future
Mill arts and Event Center so all we're
doing we're just going to substitute
going back to overview and scrutiny back
to full Council
there we go
okay
um
before we firm up on the amended
recommendations
if we could just go to other members of
the executive there's any comments or
questions in relation to the
recommendation coming through from ons
councilor sparing thank you chairman I
don't have any criticism or comment to
make further than what councilor ward
has but
unless I'm missing the point I would
have thought as as our leader said there
should been some comment somewhere
with regard to the recommendations that
were already in there that had
previously come from the executive and I
would have thought as he said can we can
we collate
your comments of your new
recommendations
with what was previously submitted
um I I you know I don't have a you know
we can answer all your comments but I
can't find
I know this is early in the conversation
and you may well have this in hand I
can't see where overview and scrutiny
actually reviewed what was recommended
by the executive
um sorry chairman I hope I'm muddy the
waters or gone too far but uh
that that's the point and I I also
um understand that you say the evidence
gathered
I'm led to believe and unfortunately I
couldn't be here that evening but
effectively
two of the parties who have expressed uh
interest
were very aggrieved that a a third party
who hadn't made the final two
had another opportunity to State their
case
um this had already gone through as far
as I can see
a scrutiny scenario scoring and all the
rest of the situation
um but you know we're perhaps I'm
judging or jumping too far Gemini I
don't know
okay thank you accounts for sparing any
other commentary executive colleagues
before we go to
Council Wilson
to sort of sum up on the recommendation
and uh listen but any other comments no
I've got no further comments on on that
recommendation of this oh okay so I
should be looking for officers to
encapsulate any amendments
um but were you amending that I mean I
know we've accepted it but were you
amending it in relation we've got to get
some structure around this and cross
refer it to the other
I've got two hands now Council Missy
Felton
sorry thank you if I understand it we
report in the recommendation made by
overview and scrutiny Standalone item
and when we get to the actual
recommendations from the original report
we'll amend that one to almost match it
because they're two of the same almost
the what overview and scrutiny could
have done was suggest an amendment to
the original recommendation as opposed
to an addition but rather than muddy the
water to use um Council of experience
terms I think there's an opportunity to
just accept one amend the other to come
in line with it and keep everybody
I was really it was a early warning to
say that I'm going to be looking for
support for support from the portfolio
holder for assets along with officers to
make sure that we put all this together
at the end you know in a well-ordered
fashion and try and blend the various
recommendations of ons and also the
executive to make some structured sense
of it all so thank you for that
councilor FD
councilor Belton said well I was going
to say basically right okay Council
Wilson generally happy with that
approach yeah okay do we want to move on
to recommendation two
um again this this is one that came up
in discussion
um and I think again it will be a
standalone one but what it relates to is
that the original asset delivery program
included the Mill Hall and
that was part of an overall program so
it was tightly connected together and
what members felt was that now that the
Mill Hall was in effect standard it's a
standalone project on its own
um so it was to say that the original
disposal policy wouldn't necessarily
follow from that but going forward it
would as I say it would be a standalone
operation
if that makes sense okay so it's a
standalone recommendation not related to
any other part of the report yeah okay
um if I turn to councilman Ward do you
wish to make a comment in relation to
that
recommendation again yeah thank you very
much indeed chairman
um
firstly I think there's a slight mistake
in regards to the recommendation itself
because there's no document titled the
asset disposal policy whatsoever
but we believe that the ons committee
are referring to the asset disposal
framework
the asset disposal framework is not just
for disposing of assets through sale an
asset will be identified as suitable for
disposal and surplus to requirements if
it cannot evidence how
it meets at least one of the objectives
outlined in the asset strategy in its
current condition and use
therefore the council cannot simply
disregard the agreed policies of the
council
therefore this recommendation is
rejected
however the council remains committed to
exploring all possible operating models
as contained within the report and it's
a shame that nothing was highlighted
that would refer
this recommendation to what is actually
in the report the report covers a lot
and this seems to have no relationship
to the report sorry to say that
thank you councilor Ward um again coming
back to any other members do you wish to
comment
councilor spurring yeah thank you
chairman
um going back on the wording as we've
talked about I think we ought to make
this very clear very early on in this
meeting there is no plan to dispose of
this building
I'm sorry that's why we're here we're
looking for the way ahead I think we
might have to say this a dozen times
tonight but that is a simple reality
we're not here to dispose of this
building we're here to work out the best
way in the most structured way ahead
thank you chairman
thank you councilor sparing anyone else
no I mean I want to emphasize that point
um that the framework applies to the
whole of the council's estate and
Disposal doesn't mean
um get rid of it actually means find and
re-engineer reinvigorate recycle and
actually find a community use for a
number of our buildings the best example
I can think of just off the top of my
head is the Clements gate Pavilion that
sits adjacent to Clements Hall Leisure
which you know has been repurposed so I
think we just got to be
I need us to be precise because this is
a governance process we're going through
um I'm not wishing to sound pedantic but
at the same time I think Clarity is
important uh the asset disposal
framework is actually for the whole of
the estate of uh Rockford District
Council the asset delivery program of
course covered six sites and of course
we've taken the Mill Hall out of the
asset delivery program so it's
Standalone and as you so rightly say I
think we might have to emphasize that
point because it's the governance
surrounding it now is quite different
from how we started out under the asset
delivery program
Jim if I must just clarify and Mr Cooper
will probably be able to elaborate on
this if if needed but there are a couple
of Club Council Pavilions that are
undergoing involvement with the
community groups at this time so whether
you would question that as disposal or
actually passing it to the community
that's that's another situation that is
ongoing in the background may not be
front and center but I can assure you Mr
Goodwin is fully aware of of two of them
well I am so he must be
and and I should have said a little
earlier welcome to
um Phoebe Barnes who's the director of
assets and Investments uh she is
actually my blind spot but uh perhaps
others will yell if all of a sudden she
puts up her hand and wants to compliment
anything that we're saying sorry Phoebe
for not introducing you earlier
um but uh
um you are just in that slightly blind
spot because I'm thinking you know
they're countable
yeah thank you for that I I do
appreciate councilor sperings uh
addendum with regard to the assets as a
whole because we are dealing with all
the assets and it is very good to
understand I don't want to muddy with
regard to this report but again
emphasizing that it goes right across
all the assets and we have got The
Pavilions that we're looking to hand
over to community use and some are
actually fulfilling that use as of now
thank you Jim
Council Wilson
um I think rounding off on this one if
you're happy with this sort of the way
we're doing this yeah and just for
clarity chair there was no
um
there was never any implication that the
Mill Hall was being disposed of that's
not what uh I don't believe the member
who who made this recommendation that's
what they weren't trying to imply that
at all I think it was clear from the
meeting that the Mill Hall was staying
and Council have all made that clear at
our meeting yeah yeah absolutely but we
had to take what he's written from your
committee
um and uh
um they're real so okay so you now
understand the reasons why it's being
rejected
um but you know
it's not to be negative about the the
asset delivery program and in relation
to this building
okay moving on to recommendation three
councilor Wilson
recommendation three relates to section
4.2 and um
it was recommended that there'd be a
cross-party working group set up to
steer the process looking at the high
level objectives for this
I appreciate we've got the partnership
panel and that was mentioned but as I
understand at the partnership panel has
got a wider remix so this was
specifically for the Mill Hall
yeah I won't steal Council Awards under
too much but of course this is back to
governance and the partnership panel
relates to the asset delivery program
and now by default The Mill Hall has
fallen out of it so but I'll let
counselor will do the response
thank you
um yeah I'm just going to add and give
Clarity to that response if I may the
report currently under consideration by
the executive is the ongoing process of
setting the future of the Mill Hall
one of the purposes of the report going
to ons was to ensure transparency and to
enable cross-party involvement
given that the Mill Hall is no longer
part of the asset delivery program and
therefore does not fall within the terms
of reference of the partnership panel
the executive will accept the
recommendation to form a separate
cross-party working group to support the
development or propose proposals of the
Merle Hall but I would like to suggest
just a slight change if you would accept
it in regards that it would Now read the
cross party working group is set up to
support the process
and I'm I'm content with that if you are
any comments from executive members
council Mrs Belton thank you
um during my short time on Council it's
always been
um certainly the ambition to have
cross-party working groups and have
people engaged that was always the case
with the asset um project it was the
program and everything else that I've
certainly been involved in we've
encouraged and it's not always taken up
quite frustratingly I fully support a
working group for this it's a massive
item it's an emotive item and I think
the more people that are prepared to put
their money where their mouth is and get
involved the better
I'm happy with the recommendation it's
original form I'd support a change if
it's welcomed I don't see it makes a
huge difference but ultimately I welcome
support from everybody on every group so
that we can get the outcome that the
community wants
and thrifting I'm also quite happy with
the recommendation it's an original form
which is still instead of support
lovely thank you councilor ft
um other comments and and yeah I I
totally support it I mean the
partnership panel has worked pretty well
on the asset delivery program and and
you know it should be quite there should
be cross-party engagement
um and without dwelling too much on the
past I have to say when the
um framework was first talked about in
2018-2019 recognizing we needed to do
something with our estate and I realized
a number of us went around there so it's
I'm not finger pointing at anyone
um
there was less than cross-party
engagement to address
um you know what we needed to do with
our assets right across the district and
so I really welcome welcome this and
just to be clear you say it relates to
section four but it doesn't relate to
one of the particular key
outcomes yeah so it relates to the 4.2
so it's the overall development of the
high level objective so we're beginning
to what we're saying is Council began to
develop its high-level objectives to the
middle arts and Event Center this is
based on uh on all the engagement
assessment I think that that panel would
then also that working group would
support that work okay no that's great
all right lovely thank you
um then we turn to recommendation four
um
counter Wilson
and again that comes in in um
section four so section 4.2 4.3 and the
idea behind this is that
in order to get the clarity of the
vision and what we expect the people
doing the expressions of interest to
produce on behalf of the council that we
revisit the market research which will
inform what we can deliver what what the
community wants to deliver so it's not
to throw the work away it's actually to
build on what's already happened
okay glad you made that latter point but
councilor Walton
thank you again chairman
um again I think a little bit more
clarity is required when we're looking
at this report because the report
recommends that a budget is allocated of
25 000 pounds to support the resources
required to develop a full business case
for approval on the Future Vision of
four The Mill Hall arts and Event Center
this allocation or budget will look to
focus on Resident assessment needs
engaging with all stakeholders to
collate all previously captured data to
formulate a proposed investment design
and business case to demonstrate how the
investment required for the building
ensures is financial sustainability for
the future
the meaningful market research data We
Gather will inform the future operating
model that allows the council to develop
that business case
as the intention will be to look at all
the options including the designs
cabin's proposal which will necessitate
a modern media facility
supporting a cinema type offering which
will require significant investment in
sound proofing and Technology
all of which is already covered by the
report therefore the executive does not
accept this recommendation as it is
unnecessary
Council Mr Felton
thank you I'm probably going to say the
same as Council award but in a few less
words
um to my simple mind the sensible thing
here would have been for the original
recommendation 2.5 to have been amended
to insert the words meaningful Market
Research into that uh paragraph and I
think that's what council of Ward was
getting at that it's already in the
report but that the wording could have
just been enhanced to meet overview and
scrutiny's um desire to have that sort
of phrase or objective in there which I
think any of us are against that
absolutely meaningful research is what
we need and we already have an awful lot
of it and the other thing I just want to
bring up and it would have come up under
2.5 but it can come up now both the
design cabin and the mega Center made it
crystal clear that they have a lot of
research as well and I I hope that part
of the process will be engaging with our
preferred Partners to work on that data
the data that we had commissioned as a
council only about 18 months ago and
then the 25 pound budget or up to 25 000
pound was for anything else that we
don't already have and also to
potentially join all of those pieces of
data together so that it becomes
something that everybody can understand
and absorb so in in refusing this
recommendation I think it's it's purely
because the basis is already covered in
2.5 and potentially we could propose an
amendment to 2.5 once we get to that
part of the report to include those
words if that would suffice and then I
think again we're taking both boxes
yeah I I'm looking at Council Wilson I
think I got a nod there but yeah no it
would I think we're sort of almost
violently agreeing with each other
because I think as long as the word
meaningful market research it's only
because market research is different
from putting a business case together is
it forms part of it so as long as that's
in there that that would be fine I mean
I I think the strange thing about this
is we're wanting to be really positive
really but we don't want to duplicate
recommendations and if we can combine
and simplify it that's what we're I mean
what I intend to do at the end of this
section is to actually adjourn the
meeting for a little while while we
actually work out so that we can
actually agree a set of recommendations
rather than just debate it and start
playing around with words and everything
so
um
we're we're rejecting four as it stands
but actually incorporating it within 2.5
is that but but the wording to be agreed
and we'll have to talk that through
later but I think to adjourn it to give
some time to work that through rather
than
um you know so Council ball did you want
to come back
yes it was just uh thanking councilor
Belton for just adding those those items
uh yeah we do have a lot of data which
is shared across the board and we do
need to access as much as we can
as well as adding to that and to see
where the holes are if there are any to
make it a complete market research thank
you lovely thank you any other member
wish to comment at all no okay Council
Wilson happy with all of that we'll move
on to
um let's see where it gets interesting
because some people have got one version
of an agenda and others have got another
but let's go on to recommendation five
as I believe the agenda should have been
published
and I think we'll be reverting back to
the agenda item up right at the end the
the uh the five at the end that there
were several versions of the agenda
published I gather through a technology
default or something that uh we'll come
back to that but let's deal with them in
the order we've got the recommendation
six on some of our agendas and five on
others of our agenda just to be clear
that that's the one that during the
process external funding that's it yeah
that's it thank you for that Clarity so
this is a standalone one that came up in
discussion with the uh groups that had
put the expressions of interest and they
were all asked whether they were
external sources of funding that were
available to them and they all Indica
well they indicated that they could
potentially have other sources of
funding
um so it was really just to make sure
that that we don't forget about those
extra sources so it's not just purely
Council funding
and I think you know the question coming
next what does that relate to in the
report does it relate to any of the
outcomes listed
um well I think sorry excuse me 6.2
um
which is about next steps upon approval
of the budgets presented within the
report officers will begin discussion
with Fusion I think we we would be
looking with the people that have put
the expressions of interest to be
looking at the putting the full budget
together
okay all right so so you're looking into
6.2 within the report thanks a lot
Council of Walton
I think I won again thank you
well uh the executive accepts this
recommendation I'd just like to to cover
a few other things that need to be said
at this stage it's too early to say what
the operating proposals and Associated
governance may be and what funding
streams may be applicable it must be
stated that we would always consider all
available funding options as part of the
financial business case such as the
community investment plan fund equally
we will support any partners with their
own funding bids but basically we accept
this recommendation
thank you Council abort any further
comments on that recommendation
Council ft
yes I'd like to agree with this it's
always best to use other people's money
legally if we can
counselor Mrs Belton
thank you and yet fully fully support
this and I think it's been spoken about
many times and the fact that having
working in Partnership actually opens up
a lot more doors than what councils are
able to achieve themselves so that was I
think always part of the conversation so
to put it in the report absolutely fine
with that is good
um obviously just to remind members that
we have gone through the shared
Prosperity fund and the Mill Hall can
potentially feature in that further down
the line and the community investment
fund both of which create opportunity
for partners for third parties to look
at match funding opportunities and so on
and so forth because I think it's always
been the intention to maximize any
investment into the Mill Hall to the to
the nth degree by using those
third-party opportunities so fully
supported and and in my mind this has
been discussed many times over
thanks councilor Belton
um any other comments before I go to
councilor Wilson to sum up
um yeah certainly I mean from top of my
head I think we've actually put in about
210 000 subject to us agreeing further
recommendations
um that are set out in 2.3 and 2.5 210
000 from the community investment fund I
think so you know these other sources of
under input funds are important
um but uh they're depending on the
governance model that's finally selected
for this place there's probably much
better opportunity than directly to uh
to local authorities on on funding
anything that you wanted to sort of sum
up on that no I mean thanks for your
support on it I think um having those
extra funding streams will reduce the
risk to the the overall risk to the
council and also hopefully enhance what
is offered to the residents as well
yeah I mean look along this long and
tiresome Journey if I can say we have
actually visited a number of uh well-run
organizations that run through trust
charitable organizations
um you know Town Council in South
Woodham Ferris we visited that facility
and they run you know yeah they work
very well and and you know that's the
model that we should be looking at so so
thank you for that right does that take
us on to recommendation
um
six I think five
six yeah yeah right okay recommendation
six Council Blues
um this relates to
um recommendation 2.6 at the progress of
the community expression of Interest
process and the outcome following this
process be noted and again it came up as
being interviewed with the people that
had put forward the expressions of
interest
and I think the the idea behind this is
there's a reset so it's not really to
throw the whole thing out it's not to
get rid of any progress that we've made
it's just to reset
to take stock of where we are and then
and then move forward because I think if
our stakeholders have got any
uncertainty and they perceive that then
I believe as a council we've got to try
and sort that out
thank you councilor Wilson
um any comments from my councilor Mrs
Belton
thank you I don't know if Council of
Ward wants to come in first sorry I beg
your pardon I bypassed you Council of
order let you come in with your sorry
aren't you naughty chairman
well
at this time the executive can't accept
this recommendation as the current
expression of Interest process hasn't
been concluded
is ongoing at this moment so you know we
we can't restart anything and do
anything fresh thank you
thank you Council of Ward councilor Mrs
Belton your turn now thank you
um right I've
been mouriness but
for a number of reasons the first one
despite some Facebook comments and some
reporting the expression of expression
of Interest process hasn't failed it
hasn't finished it's still going through
we have two preferred partners that have
worked incredibly hard to get to this
point and they made that Crystal Clear
at ons despite a third party being given
essentially an open interview to pitch
how it felt
um I think it would be completely
outrageous to start the process again to
refresh it in any way we've got two
preferred partners that are working with
officers to come up with a model that
can sustain this building and give the
community everything that it wants and I
don't believe from what I heard that
either of those Partners suggested in
any way shape or form they wanted a
refresh or a restart they certainly want
more clarity but that's something
completely different that is an ongoing
piece of work with those two partners
but I said certainly wouldn't support
the recommendation and to be honest I
was disgusted that it ended up in there
to be perfectly Frank based on what I
heard at ons and based on the work that
I've seen those two groups undertake for
many months now so I won't be supporting
it and that's why
thank you Mrs Belton council Mrs Belton
that's very clear councilor Williams
yes thank you chairman um
our preferred Partners not only have
they put an awful lot of time into this
they put an awful lot of money into this
and it would be extremely unreasonable
for us to to finish this ahead of time
so it needs to complete its natural
progress thank you
thank you councilor Williams any other
comments
no I mean look I just want to underline
um the comments that have been made so
far
um you know we're working through this
and I think it will be extremely
discourteous and disrespectful uh to
undo a heck of a lot of work I was part
of the scoring process on reaching the
uh those two final uh preferred partners
with us and ongoing work I have to
applaud their patience because other
aspects of this whole project
are not easy
um and we're doing our best to work
through and I really want to applaud
their process their patience uh with us
but it would be it's a process still
going on and it may be a little
laborious but that in itself isn't the
reason to undo it and just start all
over again the criteria and the basis
for the expressions of interest is as
sound today as it was when we did that
when we launched that process but I
think we're all getting frustrated with
the time it takes but that's not a
reason to to start afresh and uh I think
it's important to sort of you know we're
trying to back this up with logic and
structure attached to it councilor
Wilson right okay recommendation seven
and this relates to 2.6 and it's an
ongoing piece of work really it was
clear in discussion with the people that
had put the expressions of interest in
that what they wanted to be involved
with is the um the procurement and the
development of the building so they
wanted to be actively engaged for
example and Council Awards mentioned it
about the media facilities because it's
them that's going to have to make use of
it so the idea behind this collaborative
procurement is that all part Council
plus the people doing the expressions of
Interest are involved in the final
product that gets delivered
thank you councilor Wilson
um I've got it right this time Council
of wolves your turn thank you
um well the executive will always ensure
it is following the council's
procurement policies and relevant
legislation and will always look at
opportunities of working collaboratively
with its Partners we assume and I'm
going to need clarification from
yourself that the intention of this
recommendation is to consider a
collaborative multi multi-partner bid
model
to operate the Mill Hall which is
something that we will consider when
looking at possible operating models and
I think trying to understand what you
were talking about in this
recommendation I've taken that
assumption is that exactly what you were
aiming at
it is so in effect it's not the
council's interpretation of what
the people that are operating the
building need it's actively engaging
with them obviously within our
procurement Frameworks but yeah it's a
multi-agency bid
okay
because of water yes I'd just like to
come back on that we've still got to
look at the government so we've still
got to look at the models and the models
and the government and the governance
will actually be a decisive factor in
how this
multi-group actually works and I think
that's the the basis on which we have to
explore thank you thank you Council of
Ward councilor FD
thank you chairman
um if you look back to recommendation
four where we'll talk about modern media
facility
which is talking about Cinema that came
from the expressions of Interest so we
have been engaging with them all the way
through this and
this wasn't our idea it was their idea
so of course I'm sure we'd look at what
they would want to operate
um okay look
this
recommendation is is an interesting one
because I understand the spirit of it
what it's intended to do and it's about
engaging with the working group
working policy call it what you like
that we've agreed should happen
um but I have actually got to defer to
officers because there are very very
strict rules around procurement in the
local government World some that
frustrate those of us that aren't in the
local government world uh like mad and
we saw an example of that in the early
stages of this where there were huge
restrictions I mean it frustrated me
like like mad
um and I think that awful expression
that lessons have been learned from from
that but
I've really got to defer because this
isn't something that in any way the
executive want to be obstructive about
but we do have to follow a legal
governance framework so
you know I've really got to look for an
officer comment uh to support what I'm
saying or reject what I'm saying so
Emily ulys
and Phoebe is very delicately sort of
nodding ahead towards Emily so
thank you chairman
um and uh good evening executive members
um I think really this is a bit caught
before the horse chairman so until you
understand the governance model around
how the operating model might be
delivered you can't make any judgments
on what procurement process might need
to be followed
that was very nicely and succinctly put
and um you know I think that's where we
are
um from a from a compliance point of
view and hopefully you'll accept that
that in the vein it's it's intended uh
you know a lot of issues Cults and
horses and uh how we do things
happy to move on
right recommendation the the last
recommendation and
um
I've thought about this and I've
discussed this with officers and I I'm
not sure that as we're coming up to
perda that this recommendation would
actually be viable at all to hold
to hold an extraordinary Council
um
so I'd look
perhaps Mr hankin to say you know is
is this a complete No-No
Germany wouldn't be a complete No-No but
uh you know it would depend on the uh
the business which was to be conducted
here but uh obviously we want to hear
what do you reply to the recommendation
is
of course I would Mr hankin councilor
Ward
thank you
the executive has already denied his
decision making on the report
due to the ons committee's early
deferral of the item the report today is
simply seeking the executive's approval
to ensure that the Mill Hall can remain
fully operational in the interim period
the executive has already accepted
recommendation one to hold a full
Council debate on the future operating
models before any one option is selected
that is the right time for the Council
debate
and not now
when we are simply making decisions that
will keep the building operational day
to day
on that basis the executive will proceed
with the recommendations at 2.1 to 2.8
in this report with obviously the
additional recommendations that have
come forward
referral to the full Council being
unnecessary at this stage so I would say
that um
as you suggested it is probably
unnecessary because we're already
tending to this recommendation in
recommendation one
councilor Mrs Bolton
thank you
um
so when I read this I was I was
surprised because to me it was it was
jeopardizing keeping the Mill Hall open
in the short term and this report is
about the interim period it's about the
period that we're currently in of just
finding a way to operate it and ensure
that bookings can be taken and the
longevity and to staff the building
essentially so the recommendations were
some of them were slightly off-paste of
that but I understood why because they
related to other points in the report so
I mean I I fully agree with what
councilor wolves just outlined there
that if we were deciding the future
operating model of the Mill Hall in this
report absolutely I could understand why
people would want it to come straight to
full Council
the questionable bit about being before
elections is is arguable but that's a
different a different thing altogether
but we're not actually doing that in
this report this is about the interim
running operational model so I think
what council Awards said is is
absolutely right we debate this at full
council at the appropriate time where
models and working groups have met and
the expression of Interest has concluded
and at this point we're just trying to
keep this building open for the public
which is what everybody has said they
wanted
thank you councilmanship Belton cancer
FD
properties say same sort of thing but a
lot less words we want to debate new
stuff not go back over the old stuff
huge amount of work to be done and
we've got to have meetings where we can
make decisions
and move forward on some of this stuff
but did you want to come back I don't I
don't think it was the intention of the
committee
um
to be obstructive on that it came about
as I recall that members were worried
that because on the key decisions
document there was a key decision that
had to be taken and I think members were
worried that because we've delayed it
with an our committee that that would
jeopardize the future of the Mill Hall
and I think that's where this came from
so it's not something that was
um
there to be a break or anything like it
was genuine concern that did we need to
take a decision earlier rather than
later but from what's been said there's
no need for that
okay Council Wilson thank you very much
of course you're the Messenger for for
your committee so uh you've you've
pushed over those various
recommendations uh very ably but did you
want to we're still actually in your
introduction to the report going through
the recommendations uh did you have
anything else that you wish to add
no thanks chair right okay what about
the recommendation that
um
has got printed but
wasn't recommended
that that fell so that was rejected at
the meeting right okay even though it
got published
it did I think it was published in error
okay
um look let me be absolutely clear
because it was published and I think
it's regrettable it was published
um
we just end up by going around in
circles with those sorts of
recommendations it's out there so I'm
going to comment on it
um there is no suggestion we've been
through a process lots of meetings there
is no suggestion of demolishing this
building let me make that quite clear
um so you know I think it's important to
spell that out what we're trying to do
is make this a um facility which we as
I've said in the past which we can all
be proud of having been through quite a
lot of a pain process
and we are committed to to that I think
I'll probably understand why the
question might have been raised but
clearly certain people haven't been with
this at an earlier stage when original
outline business cases were being put
options being looked at we don't want to
keep going around the wheel so I want to
make it quite clear that if anyone has
read that as a recommendation it's not a
recommendation and it should be dealt
with accordingly but there is no
suggestion social media has pumped out
certain things it's latched onto it and
I think that's extremely regrettable
um because social media has a duty to
accurately report as does other areas of
the media so thank you for that right
okay so
what I want to do really is go through
the rest of the report because Council
award it's it's your report but
um
do you want to talk about other aspects
of the report in particular the key
outcomes
set out on page 6.1.2
certainly I I would like I think we're
going to be changing a few items around
but if we were to look at 2.1
upon recruitment of staff to operate the
hall and it should be the Mill Hall
notice to be served to Fusion lifestyle
to remove the mill arts and event center
from the existing Leisure contract and
to vary the contract accordingly and for
the council to undertake the operational
management of the building thereafter
and obviously this is an interim
case
I'll go through 2.2
and we can sort of find out if there's
any comments in relation to any of those
um and certainly Council Wilson I'd like
you to join in this bit because it's
important because it might be a flavor
from the ons that you can bring to any
of these points
um but members are there any comments in
relation to at this stage 2.1 but you
are amending it are you Council award
did you say you were amending it is
written that's that's right I believe
you did mention you were going to
adjourn
so we could actually put together the
recommendations so I'm reading out
recommendations that are going to change
and so we need to actually understand
how those recommendations are going to
change rather than me reading out
recommendations that no absolutely look
the the point is there isn't an
amendment because you've actually said
you want inserted mil
um for absolute Clarity in the first
line so there is an amendment by virtue
of that but it's not Material in terms
of the meaning but in terms of 2.1 is
there any general conversation around
that point nope
okay moving on to 2.2 save your breath
because we've got the report in front of
us and we can read it
um but uh is there any comment that you
want to make in relation to it you don't
need to read it out I have got no
specific comments on there
um I think it's very very important that
we actually go through these items uh
where the Amendments need to go in I
believe I I'm hoping I'm going to get a
nod from either Phoebe or Emily that
those amendments I I it's actually Emily
who has made the Amendments that are
necessary for us to look at in regards
to the additional recommendations from
ons which I would suggest chairman
respectfully that we may have an
adjournment to actually go through them
so we take them all together rather than
me doing this piecemeal right okay no I
remember that but I did ask you if
you've got any specific comments in
relation to 2.2 which is talking about
uh
a revenue budget of nearly a quarter of
a million pound I have no additional
comments on that except obviously like
any budget it is up to it's not uh you
know it's not that the amount we're
going to spend we don't know we will be
investigating everything that is
necessary in regard and this is actually
in relationship to all items that are
listed on there all the finance items
are up to and we will obviously be very
fiscally aware
of how that money is managed okay
appreciate that councilor Mrs Belton
thank you and I have previously
challenged this recommendation and and
the appendix too because of the the
figures that we're talking about here
now I come from the private sector so
when I see these sorts of figures it
makes my eyes water slightly
um but what has been explained to me and
what I accept is that this is an interim
Arrangement and I go back to the word
that I used earlier this is about
keeping the Mill Hall open in the short
term because in the short term we don't
have a private sector partners that can
come in and manage the building because
we don't know what the model is we don't
know what the objectives are yet that
works to come as we've alluded to
tonight
so I can support this recommendation and
the figures on the understanding that
this is about a short-term option to
looking after the Mill Hall and keeping
it open I just think we need to make
that clear because we don't know that
the best operating model of this
building is for officers and Council
staff to run it as we've alluded to
there's options with Partners trusts
Charities and so on and so forth so I
just wanted to bring that up because on
paper that is not a recommendation I
would support but I have asked the
question and been given the answers so
on that basis it makes more sense okay
uh Council yeah thank you yeah I'm very
happy that my co-counselor councilor
Belton has come up with that there were
items in appendix 2 which I think many
of us were not happy with as far as the
figures but this is an interim
Arrangement and we we need to be able to
be
happy that we can keep the Mill Hall
open and working until such times as a
model has been devised that can take
over
thank you councilor Ward
um
on that point I
share the general concerns but I also
accept that officers have a little bit
of difficulty because they've got Fusion
pay rates
they have Fusion pay rates and they have
office of pay rates and they have all
sorts of other pay scales but until you
actually start developing the model
needed in the interim this is a
difficult one and what officers have
done is they've that they have got some
objectivity about how they've arrived at
the figures albeit
um to use councilor belton's terms they
seem a little eye-watering I liked I
don't really want us to go for an
amendment because otherwise we just look
as if we're but but I would like
officers to bear in mind this is an up
to I thought you'll come in an
up-to-figure
um is the right approach I would like to
revert back to some traditional HR
methods of let's have a few job
descriptions around what is considered
to be a reasonable operating model in
for the interim and make sure that our
pay rate to market rate that we attract
the right to people the right caliber of
people but I think it's dangerous when
you start necessarily looking at one
industry
um you know here which is quite
different from perhaps other industries
that people work in so I'm sure officers
you've taken that on board
um but within the spirit of the
recommendation I'm certainly quite quite
happy Council Wilson did you want to
comment at all
okay
2.3
Council of war did you want to make a
general comment it's before you
generally is the same where we've
actually got additional capital budget
of up to 185
000 the up two is a very important
factor again in that in whatever
workings that will need to be done we
have to be careful in in how it's
actually spent
thank you very much councilor Mrs Belton
sorry about this but I've been but I'm
going to keep saying things because
often what we don't say is what is then
used against us so I just want to
reiterate some points and so again
looking at this the first question was
why are we investing money in a building
that we don't know how it's going to
operate we don't know what outside
investment is going to be needed we
don't know who's going to be using it
but again we've asked these questions
and the responses have had and it does
Clearly say in the table six but I still
like to just get clarity these are about
essential repairs these are about
leaking roofs fire alarms things that
have to be done regardless of what is
going on in this building it is the
essential stuff so we aren't throwing
good money after bad we aren't spending
money that we then need to spend again
because we want to change the usage I
don't like spending money twice in any
Walk of Life and so it was important to
clarify that but I trust and I
understand now that as per the condition
report and as per the officer's answers
these are the essential repairs that are
required regardless so on that basis
again it makes more sense to me
yes I mean I think again it's getting
the balance and I'd certainly and
there's emails on on uh on record
um to say that we've wanted the obvious
signs of
um building Decay
um understood and that relates
specifically to asbestos which is the
common uh question that is asked in
buildings of this type and uh High
Lumina cement concrete cancer as it's
known
and we have been assured that the
building is structurally sound
and on that basis I think we you know
feel confident that we we push ahead
Council Ahoy you're nodding your head I
wouldn't normally uh
um you just caught my eye but we
actually have those emails on on file
and they are from Rick surveyors but
um the um so sorry you just caught my
eye and I couldn't help noticing
um but certainly we are talking about
considerable investment in this building
over a number of years which we are
committing to but there has got to be
along the way the appropriate
reassurance through the appropriate
surveys to to give us confidence on that
point against reward
so councilor Hoya wouldn't you know I
mean please please
yeah look I can you know I'm more than
happy in fact I would be delighted to
make the emails uh Public public
knowledge
um because I think it's a really
important point that what we don't want
to do so and please uh you know
sometimes I break the rules and bring
other people in if I see that they're
itching to say something but uh um you
know I I have always been concerned
since we've been in the latter phases of
this that we didn't hit a fundamental
Obstacle of
um a structural defect in this building
um because there's no point in investing
and giving a commitment to invest if we
actually find that the obvious things
which we talk about these days concrete
cancer High Lumina cement which I do
know a fair bit about but I'm certainly
no expert in in professional terms and
asbestos it's the limitations that those
could offer but I think actually there's
probably further structural survey work
that we need to also give us a degree of
confidence on but I am very happy
certainly to councilors to to to make
the reports available that we've had so
perhaps officers would take that as a as
an action because I want to give
confidence to everyone but it's how you
far you go to satisfy yourself on the uh
on the structural condition of it
um sorry sir I couldn't help but I know
it's issue noting so I'm pleased to have
that clarification Council award
yeah thank you chairman I think 2.3 is
fundamentally about making this building
fully operational at least initially and
I think that's a very important factor
we want to get things going and we need
to make it safe there's a lot of items
in there in that in that list I don't I
don't need to go through them they're
all listed but they're all essential and
they are the things that need to be done
as quickly as possible and I know that's
and that's why we do need to proceed
with this report to enable that yeah
thank you and the condition survey which
has been commissioned we are committed
really for insurance purposes all sorts
of regulatory processes to make sure
that we responsibly deal with those in
the short term while we address the the
longer term commitment
could if I can also just come back on
that you know as Emily said on things
that I've been saying before we must put
the horse before the car and I believe
this is a twin track that I've been
speaking to to Phoebe about that it is
really really essential that as well as
doing this material here we are going to
need to work on the governance principle
and the various Concepts that might be
there for the models that need to be
used at the same time because I I want
to sort of move on with this to give
those expressions of Interest the
opportunity
for the conversations that we need to
have okay all right
um
yeah and obviously any uh subsequent
lease Arrangements would have to reflect
you know anyone taking on this building
needs to be given the Assurance you know
whatever
legal Arrangements that that involves
and moving to 2.4 certainly there's
going to be an amendment here because I
don't recognize the figure in there but
I think it's intended to be 45 000
pounds so that needs to be um
confirmed but I think it really speaks
speaks for itself it does indeed speak
for itself if we look around
I'm not going to say it's the most
pristine of furniture that sits around
it does need to be improved and we do we
need to make an investment in that so it
actually starts to look a bit better and
I think that's an important factor and a
more inviting
absolutely counselor Richard Belton all
right
um all I would just like to say is that
it's very vague Furniture is quite a
broad term
um whilst I recognize that there may be
some needed I would like to think that
we're future proofing and anything that
we do invest in now could be used in the
future it isn't going to be something
that has to be disregarded when we find
our operating model and I would also
just like to add especially with my
climate hat on and finance and economy
quite frankly that any furniture that we
no longer need gets repurposed reused
given to the community something is done
with it I do not want any of this to end
up in landfill because whilst it might
not be the prettiest it's perfectly
functional
well said
um right I think in terms of 2.5 we
agreed earlier that that will be looked
at in conjunction with the four item
recommendation for from ons so we can
move on from that if you're happy with
that Council Wilson
yeah happy with that we'll we'll work on
that in another Journal
um and then
2.6 Council wall did you wish to comment
on that I believe we have dealt with
that tonight yeah and it stands is that
2.7
any comments again more or less the same
uh it all we've actually covered that in
a lot of things that we've talked about
and 2.8
2.8 is is the item which was on uh
recommendation one that we're going to
look at and is going to be discussed in
the adjournment okay
um right before we move to an
adjournment are there any other comments
that anyone wishes to make in relation
to the overall report
ing
um I think
hopefully if we
vote to approve this report it'd be a
good step forward in getting this
building
up and working
I agree with that
um right okay
um
I do want to sort of place on record my
appreciation to everyone for the
constructive debate that we've had for
the last just over an hour uh on this
it's a worthwhile hour
um thank you to you Council Wilson and
your colleagues I think this is where
um we need to adjourn will 10 minutes do
it
10 minutes
officers went they can do it in five
well it's an open-ended adjournment but
five minutes but if you know we need to
extend it to get the job done properly I
don't want this rush but I'm going to
ask officers whoever they nominate
together with councilor Ward and
councilor Wilson I think a little huddle
between you I don't need to be involved
in in the recommendations so at um we'll
we'll use that clock up there
um so let's call it 20 to nine uh we'll
reconvene at a quarter to nine meeting
adjourned for the present time
foreign
is
afraid
I'm sorry
foreign
that's nice
so that I don't know
you can ever think about that
and they're now doing the work of the
council as well
foreign
yeah Jessica a lot to me
if we can reconvene please
he said all who was in charge when this
building was signed it was conservative
I said if you're always going to
degenerate the interoperative
uh
right okay
so we're very closely
okay
right
we're convening the meeting at um 12
minutes to uh to nine by that clock so
I've around slightly with the
adjournment but
um right thank you for work that has
been done in the interval
I'm told that uh office this is a double
act between officers and the Strategic
portfolio holder for planning and assets
uh you're going to get through these
recommendations so Emily do I look to
you first of all
yes please chairman so I've got the
amendments to the recommendations in the
report
to recommendation 2.1 we will insert the
word Mill in between the and Hall so it
will read The Mill Hall
in recommendation 2.2
I was trying to think should we read out
and just as we go take them one at a
time
because they've got to be read out
haven't they chairman if you're happy to
accept the Amendments that I'm repeating
yeah you can take them on block
okay right
um right are we happy to take
the amendment right okay
and Council Wilson for the purposes of
this I just want you to be happy as well
on behalf of your committee here
right
uh chairman I probably should have said
it at the end of the end of me reading
all these out or reading the Amendments
out you will need to have them proposed
and seconded before you go to the vote
but you're happy for us to do that or
the committee are happy for us to do
that on block
yeah
okay
thank you so recommendation 2.2 is to
insert the words up to ahead of the sum
of
248 950 pounds
there is no change to recommendation 2.3
in 2.4 there are two typographical
Corrections one is to add a zero to make
the value 45
000 pounds and the second is to add the
word in in between investment and
Furniture so it reads investment in
Furniture happy with those except you
need to remove the comma as well being
really pedantic and replace it with a
full stop
so that it actually reached 45
000 in the conventional sense yeah
in recommendation 2.5
we will insert the words and undertake
an undertaking meaningful market
research after the word stakeholders so
that will now read this allocation of
budget will look to focus on Resident
assessment needs engaging with all
stakeholders and undertaking meaningful
market research to collect to collate
all data to formulate a proposed
investment design
etc etc
agreed and you're happy Council Wilson
good
recommendation 2.6 is unchanged as is
2.7
and then in 2.8 it is simply to replace
the words overview and scrutiny
committee with full Council
agreed
so
chairman there are also the three
recommendations from the overview and
scrutiny committee you want to take
forward
comes down to three now does it yes okay
so those are recommendations one three
and five
and chairman in recommendation three
there is an amendment to change the word
steer to support
um
so
members will be happy with those
amendments
councilor Wilson
yeah okay
right
so we've got a set of of
recommendations before us with
amendments do I have a proposal for
those
Council of Ward thank you I'm proposing
do you have a second
counselors bearing is I'll be pleased to
second that chairman thank you very much
indeed
right do we have to read them all out
again
or can we take them as written
um okay members are you happy for us to
take them on block
right okay so if we're taking them on
Block members can I have a show of hands
a vote for those in favor of the
recommendations
that is unanimous
and a very sincere thank you to uh um
everyone that has played their part in
bringing that together the ons committee
uh and members here tonight I think
that's been a really useful
time thank you also to officers that
have brought all the information
together as well so that's good
moving on you're not quite released yet
uh councilor Wilson because you've got
the second report and I think this would
be a jolly site easier but I think
you're introducing the report from the
overview and scrutiny committee on the
one team transformation program
chairman
yes the committee we're pleased to note
the progress that's been made today
and in particular the management of
risks which are going in the right
direction and gives us greater
confidence that the program will be
successful
thank you councilor Wilson and I will
take that as a reflection of me
proposing the report last week at your
meeting so we managed to get through any
questions there and again thank you for
your committee's support on on that so
members in terms of the recommendation
there is that noted
right
we turn to item seven which is quarter
three twenty twenty two twenty three
financial management and performance
update reports and I think I turned to
council Mrs Danielle Belton to introduce
the report please
thank you
um so this is just a report for noting
and I trust members have all read the
report
um but essentially what we're reporting
on here is the quarter 3
2022-2023 Revenue budget and capital
position as set out in sections three
and four and detailed in appendices one
to four and this was pushed back a month
you'll all recall
um a request of our one five interim 151
officer Tim due to budget restraints
resourcing and so on and so forth which
we agreed it is just a report for note
in there's a small underspend
um to note but essentially all the
information is in the report it's a
matter of fact and it's just there for
members to digest
members any questions on that update
thank you very much I have no team
okay
um right so we turn to the
recommendations that set out in
paragraph 1.1 do I need to read those
out or can they be taken no it's just a
note right
um so all those recommendations are in
fact for noting and or sorry there's one
recommendation wasn't there for noting
so I'll get ahead of myself so uh thank
you very much and we turn now to item
eight which is the UK shared Prosperity
fund uh process for Distributing the
future funding uh councilor Mrs Belton
it seems to be your Roadshow tonight so
let's go over to you please I've lost
the crowd though disappointingly
um never mind so we've got three
recommendations in this report for the
shared Prosperity fund
2023-24 allocation so the three
recommendations are that the authority
be delegated to the Strategic director
and director of place in consultation
with the portfolio holder for finance
economy and climate to operate a grant
program to distribute up to 70 of the
council's 2324 UK shared Prosperity fund
allocation in line with principles set
out in the report
I'll go through the recommendations
quickly and then I'll overlap on the
report so recommendation two Authority
be delegated to the same people to
utilize the remaining proportion of the
council's 2324 share Prosperity fund
allocation to directly commission
projects and lastly that those same
people are delegated responsibility to
amend where necessary some of the
principles within the report so what
we're asking for here essentially is in
the second year of our UK shared
Prosperity fund there's just over a
hundred and fifty thousand pounds as set
out in the report spit over three
separate pots essentially three separate
interventions and the suggestion is for
intervention one and four that up to 70
of that fund is made available for
grants for people like Community groups
Parish councils so on and so forth
so the works that have been undertaken
to date a partnership group met last
week
um which engaged those people to discuss
potential options and in all member
briefing has been set up for tomorrow
for members of the council to engage and
discuss also
work has already been delivered under
the First Financial year
um Dan Goodman has turned it round in
record time and has been able to
commission deep clean of town centers
something that lots of members were
quite passionate about and those are
taking place on Sundays through March
and we have a an art project to
celebrate the king's coronation a
tourism enhancement project
supports of art trials grants towards a
Community Church a business breakfast
and lots of other bits and pieces so
Zen's done a great job to ensure that
money is spent and is spent right across
the district on community projects and
what we're asking for now is the
delegation to be able to do the same
again plus setting up the grants for
year two
thank you very much
so Mrs Belton
um any members wish to make any comments
get award
thank you chairman I really really do
support this initiative it is going to
be so so important for our towns and
Villages going forward to be able to
support them in so many different ways I
think this is a fantastic way of showing
we care for our residents thank you for
all your hard work Daniel and Daniel
fantastic job thank you
yes thank you Council of Ward I should
have welcomed Daniel Goodman to the
meeting I know he was here as a support
act so far he's had a fairly light
evening of it we haven't come up with
too many difficult questions for you
um but did you want to add anything uh
Daniel no okay right any other questions
okay now there's three recommendations
did you read out 1.3
did you is that good enough
that's I'm getting the nod that that's
gonna send out in the reports uh it's
there for everyone to see clearly we
need to vote but do you have a second of
for those um
assume that you're proposing them
counselor FD
I know you spoke a strong speech Council
of warding support but I'll give
councilor FD a turn if that's all right
um okay
um are you happy to take those
recommendations on block
agreed on that and can I ask you to
raise your hands if you're in favor of
those recommendations that is unanimous
good thank you very much indeed members
um if we now turn to the final item on
the agenda for this evening and that is
to turn to a year in review update and
we're going to be looking at a
presentation except I gather the
presentation is on good old-fashioned
paper
um because we haven't got a projector
here tonight
um but I did ask for these to be
produced have have um
visiting members got copies yep okay
lovely okay right good
so
um am I introducing this
yeah that's a nod isn't it right okay
before you use a set of slides members
um and uh I want to just remind you
because I think this is a really good
and positive item that this whole
Council can be really proud of in terms
of what has actually happened there is a
bit of a tendency when
we move on through the year jobs get
done
job done checked and it's in the past
and what this is is really an
opportunity to reflect
um
everything that we do is against the
business plan of which you should all be
familiar and outcomes in relation to our
objectives by 2023 it was a three-year
business plan last year an annual review
was produced a nice glossy celebrating
successes but I'm pleased to say that
much more this year has been achieved
even than last year and we've published
Rockford District matters that has gone
out to every address because not
everyone wakes up in the morning and
time turns on their computer and checks
to sort of see what Rochford District
Council is doing so some people really
prefer a paper copy other people sort of
say why waste paper so you have to get
the balance on these things but
what we have before us is a set of
slides and I think if everyone is
prepared we're going to go through those
slides
um portfolio holder by portfolio holder
we won't make it too long drawn out but
just pick out the highlights but if we
look at page one for example
um
through the last year 13 months we have
been putting through the one team
partnership with Brentwood Borough
Council if you look at the putting in
the structures preparing the job
descriptions and dealing with all the HR
outside of putting in the leadership
team it is has been at a phenomenal Pace
to have achieved what we've done in 13
months is nothing short of phenomenal
and I think officers for how they've
navigated their way through that we do
still have three director appointments
to make substantive appointments because
three of our appointments at the pro at
the moment are interim appointments
but that has been put together
there are further interviews planned for
next week but there has always been a
policy by this executive to make sure
that um you know we recruit High Caliber
people for the positions that we're
demanding because the the two districts
um the other thing that we're very aware
of is to make sure that we have
a process for career development so that
we don't always resort to external
Recruitment and that is having launched
the aspiring managers program to grow
our own from within you know it is
important that officers feel valued
there's a clear mentoring development
program and that has been launched
we delivered a balanced budget a few
weeks ago and I've got to say for this
Council it must be the Envy I listened
on the news this morning to how many
councils are having to cut services to
balance their budget and when I look you
know budget is an interesting one
because you're not going to get everyone
always to agree
um but we should be proud collectively
across all 39 councilors of what we've
actually achieved and what we're
delivering no cuts to Services no
subsidies from reserves our Leisure
facilities preserved cleaning and
Greening no loans no debt Community
grants and a attractive program of
capital investment across the district
you know that is something for us all to
be very very proud of and you know we
have stability there
if I turn to a seller you'll see the
city fiber installing 25 million pounds
worth of full fiber enabled internet
services that links into a seller we
strengthened the acellular partnership
um there's much better Financial
accountability governance through a
joint committee defined work streams but
not set so much that we're not blind to
the fact that the world within local
government the Devolution agenda is
coming down the tracks and we have to
make sure that within a seller we're
flexible to to do that we invest sixty
thousand pounds a year in their seller
partnership and that's a partnership
with the six South Essex authorities
together with
Essex making up the seventh huge
commitment by Essex but just if we look
sometimes it's difficult to quantify the
return that we're getting there but I
can tell you that a seller has had 6.9
million pounds of Grants to develop just
one strand of what it's all about which
is a seller digital across the um across
the district
um you know and that involves going
across boundary Castle Point Basildon
you know other but you know 6.9 million
pounds has come from Grants to enable us
to distribute
um fiber in the district
and if I look back at July 2021 just 8.1
percent of our district was covered with
fiber connectivity if I look and we were
seventh out of eight I think it was
um
certainly we were low down the Lee
um if I look as at today we pulled up
the league we're about third with
49.16 those are the latest published
figures of our district being covered
with fiber
availability and we had have now as a
district overtaken the Essex and the
England average which sits at the
mid-40s uh 40 so you know that is an
achievement for our district I know it's
inconvenient when you see roads being
dug up and tracks being put in but
residents and businesses are crying out
for uh for digital a seller has been a
deliverer of that to public buildings
through that Grant so sixty thousand
pound per year investment on that work
stream alone and I wanted to sort of
really emphasize it that is what this
Council and a seller is delivering
um I just want to finish off by talking
about the connect program in 2020 early
2020 there was a commitment to invest
nearly half a million pounds in updating
and transforming our services and
obviously that program was built around
a payback over time in terms of
efficiency cost benefits and as at
current time in Broad terms we're about
350 000 pounds spent into that program
and that is delivering huge benefits I
think the last time I looked at the
figures we could quantify the return and
ongoing benefits of 177 000 pounds this
is about modernizing our services
modernizing our systems investment in
I.T investment in our Workforce and
systems to support it so I think that
covers off
the main headings on one
um sounds if I've got a question Council
Rowe
thank you
to
agree everything you've said chem I
think we should be proud as a council of
what's gone on
um
for me
the balanced budget delivery was
excellent and I've spoken to many other
councils recently and many other
councilors who absolutely Envy their
envious of our budget
we just got to look around us and see
how many accounts are up to the councils
are up to the rise in debt and I think
we should be extremely proud I know I am
and I'm I'm proud to be a counselor of
this Council chairman okay
thank you councilor Mrs Rowe right
um enough yeah that was a double act
wasn't it on the front page so so there
we are we move on to finance economy and
climate Council misses Danielle Belton
did you want to comment at all
thank you
um yeah just to say that when I was made
portfolio holder initially for climate
and economy Finance has been added but
you've both ably covered the the pros
off there
um I was asked to work on raising the
profile of businesses in our district
and also
um highlighting the climate issues that
we're facing and doing some good work to
achieve that
and for me
getting a robust sustainability strategy
approved has been a big tick in the Box
because out of that already we've set up
a climate Forum with parishes all across
the district so that we're not
duplicating work and duplicating
resources we're working together
we have an EV strategy session coming up
for stakeholders we surveyed over 2 000
people in the district to find out what
they wanted we've launched Reba which
has the best part of 200 businesses now
signed up all of whom are committed to
reducing their carbon footprint and we
have the climate committee established
so where climate is concerned I think
we've we've made some leaps forward and
we'll continue to do the work to hit our
ambitious carbon neutral Target for the
council but also bigger picture for the
district
and then going on to economy and
businesses there's been massive amount
of work done with businesses namely
Daniel and Paula working with them to to
Really highlight them the Business
Awards absolutely fantastic and
something that we should all be proud of
being involved in and I look forward to
seeing more of them in the future
we've delivered multiple one-on-one
packages to new businesses helping them
to grow and develop
we've held one but another one's coming
business breakfast with multiple
attendees and really great feedback
we're reaching just under two and a half
thousand or just around two and a half
thousand businesses every week without
tell me more business bulletins that go
out are 7.7 Rising subscription over the
last 12 months is enormous and that is
Testament to the work that Paula and Dan
do to reach those businesses and support
them
um working with the likes of the Chamber
of trade and then obviously as we've
alluded to and spoke about this evening
we've got the UK share Prosperity fund
the team got together an investment plan
in record time we've got our million
pound and we will deliver that for the
community so I'm proud of what we've all
achieved over the last 12 months and
thanks to the officers that have given
me the support to do that
thank you councilor Mrs Belton councilor
Rowe
sorry chairman you'll get sick of my
voice now
um
so I've been to the chamber trade
meeting tonight and there was nothing
but compliments for
us as a council
for Dan and Paula in fact for all of us
in general so just want that minute
thank you
thank you that's nice to hear any other
comments or questions no okay we go to
councilor ft who will talk to us about
customer services legal I.T Leisure and
tourism
thank you chairman I think I've got the
longest title there so I think in the
future I just said portfolio to put on
their safe shopping carts but first
thank you's got to go to our staff
we're at the top here we're the public
face a lot a lot of the time of the
council and everybody underneath
everybody
our staff of what makes us to deliver
these great things that we've been
delivering
um
as Council wooden alluded to we've got
our new what's your District matters out
which we got out pretty quickly and I
think it's got a really good publication
thanks uh Greg for organizing that with
uh Anna and Martin that's really great
um we've got some
I think we get quite a lot of times we
wonder where the 106 money goes when we
get a
developments in the district and so
we're actually getting some football
pitches which is great
and tonight we've actually voted on
getting customer services in the Mill
Hall properly done so that's something
else which is really going to help in
mainly I think
should be really good
um we've also looked at gov Wi-Fi now
but we won't know what gov Wi-Fi is but
that is all the government buildings now
if you've got a
um Council laptop you don't have to put
your passwords in they all just you walk
in and they all should just work
which was a good bit of work to do
there's so many things even from what's
on this one I did ask for the most stuff
but I think housing is are for
Williamsport failure has beat me just a
little bit with three pages
so that's really good
um
we've got the self-service kiosks in
reception which people now don't have to
make trips to if you live in lady they
have to go to South Stream Oxford they
can update all their digital
information to offices that's really
good
um
I will
I think my my thank you is to the staff
to make that's made all this really
possible
so any questions
thank you councilor FD
no questions good uh presentation on
your part we move on to councilor
sparing
thank you chairman
this time last year I was having a lot
of sleepless nights facing the prospect
of our voice service coming to the
series coming to an end and initially
there were 14 expressions of interest
that dropped down to nine that dropped
down to one
and the pricing was going up every time
we had a conversation this was the first
time that I can recall our work in
relationship with Brentwood really
kicked in
it was suggested that perhaps we should
have a chat with this little outfit
called Norse who we'd never had
experience of working with before I
think in the space of two weeks Mr
hotton supplied them with a lot of
information he and I went up to Norfolk
met the guys we went through their their
Murph operation
which is the noisiest thing I've been in
since I was in the ship's engine room
we then had about a three an hour
quarter uh meeting with them they told
us their proposals their ideas
and as we came out we basically looked
at each other and said you know we can
work with these guys
if it hadn't have come off not having
your bins collected streets cleaned and
all the rest of it would have been an
absolute nightmare
I'd like to think that residents have
not really noticed any change
from our point of view Rochford North
management is vastly superior to
anything we've experienced before
we've also had the benefit of using
norse's experience with other councils
across the country so if ideas are
raised to us we're not only just given
our own ideas we're using their
experience and we have a terrific
working relationship so from that point
of view I'd like to congratulate
everybody was involved in in that
project and still is
part of that of course was the
investment in new vehicles which have
been ongoing we are always open to
further ideas of rechanging alterations
and that will be an ongoing scenario
earlier in the year we had the
opportunity to celebrate her majesty the
Queens then the Queen's
Golden Green canopy event and we planted
70 native hornbeams in Cherry Orchard
Country Park we chose the hornbeams
because from experience we realized that
these trees are far more successful in
surviving and growing in the summer we
had this year was quite tactful attacked
for on everything we tried to do but at
the moment as I'm aware most I think
perhaps two are struggling everything
else at the moment seems to have
survived
we've continued our parks for nature
policy and so far have planted best part
of the 3000 trees in three locations and
that will be ongoing later in the year
chairman
we also worked with Essex wildlife
to improve the biodiversity of the lake
in Cherry Orchard Country Park and the
constant water flow that that
experiences
big project well done and and very well
received
uh another area of investment has been
in the Hockley Woods play Space
if anybody's been up there
you know I hope they're benefiting from
it
I hope they also appreciate although it
comes under another category the new car
part that's all that's open invested
another hundred thousand chairman and
all the new fencing around there
we've also supported local economies by
the free parking in the run-up to
Christmas which is almost standard now
but we did that and probably last but
not least we have secured 186 000 our
share of sep money which will secure
projects across the district in the
fourth coming year not least of all the
highway Rangers chairman thank you
thank you councilor sparing any
questions for councilor sparing before
we move on
nope okay councilor Williams I can only
uh say that with three pages you're
being quite greedy on this slide
presentation but lots going on under
your portfolio so if you want to give us
a little bit of an account thank you
thank you chairman all right chairman
members this is this report speaks for
itself
I was a bit more surprised to see what
we have actually achieved this year it's
incredible
it was easy with such a great team what
a fantastic review of course these
things don't just happen there is an
awful lot of hard work that goes on in
the background
I'm especially proud of our response to
the ongoing costs of living and the
energy crisis along with the very
successful warm Harbors initiative
supported by ravs all of this are very
very short notice
this is a fantastic effort from Air
officers and their teams and I would
like to take this opportunity
opportunity to personally think the more
thank you all
um
and of course to the previous portfolio
I ordered cancel my web who initiated
some of these projects I am proud to be
a member of this executive and this
Council
and last but no means leaves I'd like to
thank in her absence Mr Lily it's uh
she's done a fantastic job in a very
short space of time so thank you all
thank you chairman
thank you Council Williams
and finally in terms of updates Council
award
thank you chairman
well what I've got to say
is firstly wow I had no idea until you
actually see it all on paper exactly
what a fantastic fantastic Council this
is there's no doubt about it
but I'm also extremely disappointed
that members of the public
have decided to go
and not even bother to listen
to what is actually our great
achievements in this year and that
disappoints me extremely they have
walked out after just listening to One
event which again we can say the Mill
Hall is open and I'm going to repeat it
Mill Hall is open
they put that on recording and they put
it on Facebook and yet
they have decided to leave the meeting
without listening to anything that we
have done in this year on this review
which I believe is a fantastic
achievement which I have to praise all
the fellow
we have one thank you I acknowledge one
several other members thank you who are
here but those who were recording have
left
I mean as far as
what strategic planning and assets have
done for me assets was how can I put it
I came late to the party on this one I
was given a Christmas present
of assets to try and sort various things
out and you know as Dave said about
Norse and wise collection I think I've
had a few very very late nights in
regards to trying sorting out the
problems that we have actually finalized
this evening which is Mill Hall and how
that's going to go forward and I think
that is fantastic
we as far as planning is concerned which
people don't tend to take much notice of
per se but we have actually
approved 78 of the planning applications
has seen
councilor sparing did mention the
hundred thousand investment in Hockley
Woods car park
we've had a one million investment in
Clements Hall and Raider Leisure Center
the Civic Suite has been closed and the
relocation of the citizens advice and
RDC reception as councilor FD mentioned
in his report has now taken up residence
in their home
over a thousand planning applications
determined and I think you know we tend
to underestimate we we are very critical
here in Rochford of our planning
department and I'm going to say that but
it is remarkable throughout the country
we have one of the best planning
departments in the country I know a lot
of people don't particularly notice that
but it's a fact
we have delivered 456 new homes and this
is an important announcement in saying
that this year because I know people
talk about we haven't got the
infrastructure there's too many homes
too many cars but it is vitally
important we actually have these homes
coming through
basically because
we have got a superb record of delivery
and that record
is actually protecting this district
from unwanted developments and I think
residents need to understand that
there's more to planning
than the things that they actually think
about
we've had major employment growth
approved for ipco and the arterial Park
we know it's been slow and we know we've
had covid we've had a pandemic and
everything in the shutdown
and it's been difficult economically
but it is growing and there are great
opportunities that we can see on the
horizon in conjunction with the airport
and the work we are doing with them
which I think is important to highlight
we have got 675 000 pounds committed
from the community investment plan which
is going directly to Regeneration and I
think that's really the end point that
we have to look at we are growing we are
regenerating and we are making this
District even better and so I have to
say that I am so proud to be part of
this Administration that is Forward
Thinking and is able to bring forward
its vision and its plans efficiently and
with fiscal Prudence thank you chairman
thank you Council Ward any questions on
Council board okay
um right so in conclusion uh I'll sort
of wrap things up thank you very much
indeed for your various presentations
um I think the slides are excellent
um if I go through leisure
you know two excellent Leisure centers
that we have here refuse cleaning and
Greening
these are the things that
are the bread and butter services but if
they go wrong they're the things that
get all the attention
our business engagement this year the
launch of Reba
the grant system that we do
citizens advice routes come to
immediately to mine but there's others
that we support
our responsible approach towards climate
change the work that our revenues and
benefits people do day in and day out
supporting those in hardship
particularly addressing the cost of them
we have been noted as an authority that
is ahead with what we're actually doing
to support our residents and those in
particular hardship and schemes which we
launched in our budget and we didn't get
Universal support for
our approach towards Community safety a
hundred and twenty thousand pounds this
year to deliver what we hope will be a
CCTV program in Rayleigh and supporting
Community safety this is what allows
people to walk around our streets and
hopefully feel safer they should feel
safe and within a district council that
has an overall budget of about 12
million pound we punch way above our
weight
it is a great shame
that the good work that we do is
sometimes eclipsed by other issues which
though important are whipped Up Normally
on social media to a disproportionate
level
instead of flaunting the huge successes
that our officers do day in and day out
to support us counselors and I'm
actually talking about all 39. and I
think it is a shame while social media
is good in many respects it allows those
people that want to be the minority
voice to have a disproportionate voice
in in bringing some of these things down
but certainly I want to pay tribute to
our officer team
you know not everything goes wonderfully
well but a lot does go very well but
under the 80 20 rule we often end up by
talking about the 20 not going quite so
well versus the 80 that's going
extremely well so I want to thank you
for your attendance tonight thank you
for what you do day in and day out and
the success of this Authority and I want
to thank members here tonight thank
visiting members who've stayed the
course thank councilor Wilson for the
constructive contribution from ons and
to enable us to come up with what I
think are some really helpful
recommendations to move uh the Mill Hall
arts and events center there is no
desire at all to want to be destructive
in the process quite the reverse we
actually want to see this place be a
success and certainly from discussions
that I've had with certain members
who've visited other places I've indeed
been to other places we're confident
that we can make this place a jewel in
the crown we accept that it's been a
difficult pathway but I would just like
to see some more positive media in the
um in the social media world but for our
part thank you very much indeed to
everyone thank you and with that at uh
well we use that clock again 9 30 this
meeting is closed thank you very much
indeed